everybody's looking for so much outside
validation that they're impatient they
want to show everybody that are
successful thus they're rushing into
things you have 23 year olds who think
that they don't have their life figured
out yet they're living for another 80
years patience has been huge for me most
people hear the word patience and have
it confused with complacency laziness
lack of ambition it's not true i
actually think patience has been
foundational my success i decided to
build my dad's business for him for the
first 12 years of my career that
required huge patience from somebody who
thought they were great i didn't even
start quote unquote until i was 34
patience is huge it's huge and people
don't want to do it because they want
instant gratification and more
importantly instant outside validation
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
gary vaynerchuk and my take on his top
10 rules of success enjoy
rule number two start seriously life is
about
understanding the alternative
it's really hard
to complain about what milk was put in
your starbucks when you came from the
dirt
so
so you know there's a lot that we don't
need to touch on in this room
i could talk about
what i think you should be doing from a
content standpoint because the reality
is i promise you
the number one variable of growing your
business in this room that is practical
achievable doable
is how serious you take making content
on the internet
it's
that simple no matter
what anybody in this room says to me of
why no because they've never started and
they have an ideology or because they've
made 45 posts on instagram and haven't
sold anything yet no matter what your
excuses
i promise you
social media is not broken in that story
you're the one that's broken it was
funny last week someone's like gary my
you've been talking about linkedin and
he showed me
the posts and he's like it's not working
and in the post i'm talking about making
content in the feed of linkedin
knowing who you're trying to reach
running ads against the employees of
those organizations
for content in the feed
and then i ask him what he's doing
and he's spamming people
by paying a hundred bucks a month for a
script that just emails people on
linkedin
that little story is something i think
about every day
the roi i like to say of a basketball is
billions of dollars for lebron james
it's zero for me
how one plays with the tools is the
variable of success
and so
we can get into the mindset very much
the intro which was lovely thank you and
in depth i i do believe that the far
majority
of what is the opportunity in this room
or the limitation
sits in two very simple categories
one's uncomfortably black and white
and one is remarkably gray
the black and white is what i just
started with
until
you start making
dozens of videos pictures and written
articles a week
you will continue to leave an
extraordinary amount of money on the
table and somebody sitting next to you
is going to do it and take your market
share and i don't care if you've been
the queen of that city for 30 years and
work on your reputation slowly but
surely you will lose because that's what
always happens in business
if that wasn't the case ibm would still
be winning i i love this industry and i
love og's because my dad's an og ami i
started so young i'm an og like i love
og life and it is absolutely building on
reputation but i love when an agent says
to me dear you don't get it i dominate
this town for the last 30 years i'm like
dear you don't get it
you don't get it much bigger companies
than you have gone out of business with
audacity
and it is audacity
in 2022
it is it is only and this is very clear
if you're sitting in the crowd and
you're not doing this work it's only two
things and they're both interesting
one
is audacity
you're audacious that what you did in
1993 or 2001 or 2007 is enough for you
to dominate 2022
or
you've lost your ambition which is okay
i don't think of that as a bad thing
i don't think it's a bad thing that
you're not as hungry maybe you've
scratched your itch
maybe you do want to do other parts in
your life
but look don't lie to yourself
and understand yourself on where you are
in your journey
2022 is going to be a remarkable
opportunity for this room
the question is very simple though who's
going to actually put in the 30 hours of
work starting today to actually know how
to do pictures and videos and written
words on these platforms and who's not
and it becomes a very simple game it's a
black and white prescriptive game either
you're good at it or you're not no
different than basketball rule number
three choose people over profits it is
very clear to me
25 years into my career
that
kindness
and empathy
and patience
and humility are actually the
foundations and i think the things that
all of us think about as soft skills
and emotional intelligence
are actually
the hard skills that it is far easier
for me to find people who are good at
the task or have good math skills than
it is to find people who are capable of
being the bigger woman or bigger man in
the face of pressure or adversity
and so
for 20 years or so this has been in my
subconscious
code
like for many of us gave me a time to
reflect and i immediately went into
writing the book
uh
on a couple of reasons one
i'm incredibly aware that there's a lot
of young people paying attention to my
boobs
are fans of what i do
and i thought it would be
a
disservice if i wasn't incredibly
aggressive in my communication
on the things that i see as a winning
formula
it becomes double important when i
realize that most people don't talk
about kindness as the single alpha skill
in building a successful empire
and i thought it was a unique take it's
also very nuanced the reason the
subtitle is ingredients is when i was
going through my process i realized oh i
never just deploy empathy i never just
deploy patients in every situation
it's actually three or four different
traits often traits that are in a
conflict with each other
it's very interesting to be tenacious
and ambitious
while being patient
and so i i liked the concept of
ingredients because it's like cooking a
meal i think we all believe that sweet
and sour chicken is something that is
delicious but sweet and sour can see
that conflict so
i felt that i was the right person at
the right time
and what has transpired in the last 18
months because i wrote the book very
quickly in the beginning of kovid
obviously takes time for it to come out
and things of that nature
many of us are thinking about things in
the business world around the concept of
the great resignation
and
and the concept of people even applying
into businesses in the first place in a
world of options
i think
the
importance of being a leader that
understands these traits has even
compounded
in the last 18 months since i even wrote
it which feels serendipitous and
exciting for me and
i i really hope that people also
if they read it realize this is not a
book
that is meant to over cuddle the
millennials or gen z
this is truly believing that this is the
alpha
infrastructure
to building significantly large
successful businesses rule number four
embrace change what blows my mind is
people's inability to put in the work in
the face of information
all of you know that this blockchain
thing is brewing you've definitely heard
about bitcoin at this point you've
probably maybe heard of ethereum it's
happening and it's going gonna affect
this industry soonest
this is the book industry for the
internet the blockchain is contracts
please understand that
please it's a very important thing
please spend 15 hours googling ethereum
and smart contracts get educated
not to play defense
but to play offense
you do 15 to 30 hours of homework you
might just change your career
you might shift slightly in what you're
doing now to something else
it's a remarkable time and one thing i
know about an immigrant-centric reality
is it's not scared to put in the work
and i really know this statement
it likes to pick which work it wants to
do
people don't like change
and change is the only guarantee what
the blockchain eventually will do
is change the face of what brokerages
leverages in the ecosystem
right now is the time to build your
personal brand on the internet and i
mean right now
how you do that can be totally different
you don't need to be over the top or
curse like me you need to be you
i'm me
you be you
but what you need to do is start
producing content to educate people on
who you are
if you're uncomfortable with the way you
look and you want don't want to be on
video then do audio and do a podcast
if you're not sure that you can handle
the camera then write on linkedin or
facebook
if you feel more comfortable being the
hostess with the mostest start a
facebook group regionally within your
area one of the greatest arbitrages in
this industry right now is starting a
facebook group for the local area where
you sell
around the town not around selling homes
bringing people in building community
and then just happening to be the person
that's hosting that group
and picking up the business
these are the black and white tactics
available to you
how you build your team and how much
empathy you have for the consumer on the
other side is the other variable but the
opportunity is staggering it is
staggering
the speed in which people are changing
what they consume which then dictates
what they think which then dictates how
they buy
is at a level we've never seen before
i come here
fly across the country and fly back
for one reason to put so much pressure
on this room to do the homework
to do the homework
i mean it
[Applause]
the
the opportunity is so real you are
literally one
one
because i'm on the receiving end of
these messages you're one viral
tick-tock video away from selling 13
homes because of it
and you don't go in there and start
doing the latest dance you're trying to
sell homes
and you're more than welcome to shake
your ass fine but
but
it's a lot more interesting to talk
about what you want to talk about
but making it contextual to the room
people say no so much
face excuse me tick tock's fastest
growing demo
is 38 to 55 year olds
you can still think it's 12 year olds it
hasn't been 12 year olds for two years
that's the game of no versus the game of
yes
that's the game of staying curious
the biggest biggest vulnerability to
people in business today trying to sell
to human beings
is their unbelievable
calmness and interest in saying the word
no
and their visceral reaction to the idea
of maybe
the innovation that we're living through
is big
the opportunity is even bigger
but this requires homework
before you decide that content on social
media can't sell for you did you really
do the 20 hours of homework and the 50
hours of you doing it it doesn't count
when you have your niece do six posts
for you
this world is reading about push-ups
instead of doing them
i wish actually that's not even that's
actually not even true i wish this was a
game of people reading about push-ups
and not doing it we're not even reading
about push-ups we're dismissing push-ups
before we even read about them
i ask you and implore you here today my
friends
to open up your heart to curiosity
to open up your eyes to the reality of
what's happening in our society and how
people are making their decisions
and to shed your preconceived notions
and start putting in the work for a lot
of us me included
it was easy to put in the hard labor
right it was easy to put in the work
it's much more challenging to figure out
the new technologies
the problem is the world doesn't care
about you and me
the world's going to do what the world
does
and the way people are going to make
buying decisions are going to be based
on the people they see here
period
and the story and if you're not showing
up here in 2022 you're not showing up
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five develop emotional
intelligence i believe that we are born
with a lot of our traits i believe we
are then parented and some of the traits
go up and down i believe we are
environments of our neighborhood our
country our culture
when i tell you the thing that comes
least natural to me in the world
is candor one on one and for me to see
where i am today as a 46 year old man
everybody in this room has the ability
to grow in many of these attributes
most don't want to put in the work
most would prefer not to do the things
that come hard to them
[Music]
most would hope that it goes unnoticed
nothing goes unnoticed
people may not tell you
but nothing goes unnoticed
i believe in the human spirit the world
is very black and white to be on this
one people evolve people change
people can get stronger at certain
things people can get weaker at certain
things and so
i am incredibly optimistic
on humans capacity
to
evolve
what it requires
is first acknowledging its truth
seeing it
one of the reasons i produce the content
that i produce
is with the hopes that just one when i
do this right now
literally when i tell you
that i'm just hopeful that one person in
this room
is listening and something triggers
one
because that's profound
saying a couple of sentences
that shift
a person's perspective which allows them
to start building
a better place for themselves and the
people they love
is a great gift and i take on that
responsibility and i think everybody in
this room
who is fortunate enough to be in a happy
place
has a requirement
to start communicating it because we
live in a world today
where negativity
is incredibly loud
and positivity tends to be silent
and i think if you are positive
you have an obligation to your fellow
man to communicate it and make it louder
rule number six work hard do i believe
that work ethic
is a foundational piece of success yes i
do do i want anybody ever to work so
much
that they get depressed of course not i
you know i never think that money is the
driver and so i think i think whether
it's lazy headline reading for not doing
homework
yeah it's it's not been it's not been
the most fun to get dragged into no yeah
i was like oh i found reading
no and there's so many people who are
proof of the words that you say me
included um so so yeah it's like um
listen there's a there's a byproduct of
success
you know
where
people will you know
hustle porn's a term leverage poor is a
term
leveragepreneur is when you're using
other people to build yourself up
at the cost of the other person
and you know i think that though you
know as you get bigger people will
leverage you and i'm okay with that
because the truth always wins in the end
and
you know i know the body of work that i
put out my intent
um and if you want to
clip one thing or one
definitive statement from one talk
without the context of the whole thing
of course you can say anybody says
anything
but the reality is is that you know i uh
i believe work ethic is important if you
want to achieve hyperbolic success i
don't want to tell people how to be
happy yeah so why are you telling me how
i should be happy
uh and there's plenty of people that are
super depressed that work 40 hours a
week like it's just hyperbolized link
baiting leverage panoring and i'm okay
with that but at the same token it's
important not to uh not take other
people's points of view into account and
i'm i'm in a constant you know focus of
that as well rule number seven learn to
deal with fear my belief is that fear
is powerful and however you were brought
up or what your ideology is on safety
you put having a job
on a pedestal as something that's secure
the logic for all of us listening to
right now is if you're making double
what you make in there it seems like a
very obvious step but i'm empathetic
that you're scared to make that jump
my thing to remind you and people out
there in a similar situation is
it's not very hard
to get another job
if you fail
if you leave this job and so for me if
we were friends and we talked all the
time the thing i would always remind you
every day is if you take the leap of
faith and some reason it doesn't work
which by the way if you're making double
your salary as a side hustle
if you give a hundred percent of your
time to that i have a funny feeling it's
going to work out but i would remind you
that you could always go and get a job
again
in the same industry maybe for a
different company believe it or not and
i've seen this sometimes for the same
company because they missed you
that's what i would pound into your head
because whatever you grew up with it
created an ideology that a job was safe
does that make sense to you mo yeah
absolutely thank you very much listen
before before you leave you need to
re-listen to that over and over and over
every human being is the byproduct of
what they listen to so if you're
listening to your parents or a plus one
or somebody else that's saying no no no
no don't make the jump you're not gonna
make the jump if you listen to somebody
who's saying something practical like
take the jump and oh by the way if it
doesn't work you can always go back and
if it fails who cares about other
people's judgment then you'll jump rule
number eight innovate your mindset this
is a very simple business conversation
if you want to sell things it's a good
idea
to make it easier for people
to buy from you
and so the innovation is the mindset
the innovation is
going home now and deciding what you
just saw in this talk and saying is he
right or is he wrong
and if you find yourself saying
he's right but i don't want to i really
mean this that's okay
but then you have to be honest with
yourself of where you are in your career
whether that means maybe doing something
else because you don't have fire for it
or
being content which is fine a beautiful
thing if you're content but you have to
be aware that this is all happening
around you
i i don't want to tell this room how
much innovation is going on in this
space you've got the biggest technology
companies in the world interested in
your money i know what the big tech
companies are doing
i know what's happening with blockchain
i know what's happening with the 20 year
olds that everybody makes fun of who are
picking up incredible market share from
a lot of you because they're actually
being seen on social they may not know
the
business yet
and you love making fun of them for that
i got bad news for you that they'll
figure out
yeah that's that's
you may need to take a pause on that one
people make fun of things until they
don't
everybody made fun of the kardashians
until they didn't everybody made fun of
tesla till they didn't
everybody made fun of my pictures until
they sold for a million dollars today on
christy's
congratulations
people love to make fun of things and
what i'm worried about is this room's
too successful
that's a great
success
is the beginning of the end
what are some of those
you know you've you've spoken candidly
about your parents and the meticulous
upbringing what are some of the things
they taught you
that now even get you to sit here and
give back in such a fashion
my
i think gratitude is the reason i give
back
i think the single reason i want to put
out all the content and
do things like
i'm very compensated for a speech like
this but no longer
does that make financial sense to me in
my business world it's just
amazing to be here with all of you
i love it
why
because i know how i communicate i know
that i come here with an agenda and that
agenda
is to suffocate one person in this
room's bullsh
with the hope that it's exactly what
they needed to go do something
so that in four years they could send me
an email and say i was in san diego in
2021 and i thought it was hot [ __ ] but
then you got me and then i got my [ __ ]
together
then i got my [ __ ] together and now my
family's so much better life and that
feeling for me is better than even when
i'm winning
so my my selfishness is my selflessness
it's fun for me i'm already good you
know it's very easy to give when you're
fulfilled
right and so
for me
what happened
a
my family heritage was crazy up
my mom lost her mom at five my dad lost
his dad at 16. we lived in the soviet
union a lot of people don't know this i
didn't realize how many people don't
know this you weren't allowed to leave
the country the country was a prison
from 1918 to 1990 a prison you weren't
allowed to leave
leave
everybody spent time in jail
because the government owned everything
cuba and venezuela are a vacation
compared to soviet union in the 50s 60s
70s and 80s
so
you know here i am we left in 78 i'm
three years i'm growing up in america
but and this is gonna really hit for
this room i'm growing up in america but
am i really
because in my four walls it's russia
right but but but i both right so in the
house all i'm hearing every friday night
and on the weekends is the stories of
the old country and it's a disaster and
i'm out here drinking coca-cola and
watching mickey mouse
and so
very quickly i'm just thankful
i'm just grateful
and so gratitude was big
the the other thing they taught me was
it the story looked like this sixth
grade nintendo explodes
right
and i'm like mom nintendo and she's like
good go get it
and so you know that framework
gets you serious about lemonade and
washing cars
and shoveling snow and so my parents
taught me a level of work ethic that i
would in hindsight at 45
say is was probably too extreme the
three of us talk about it a lot i think
all of us collectively look at each
other and say maybe we took it to 130
100 would have been fine 80 would have
been fine we lived in 130 i worked from
the time i was 14 i worked every weekend
and every summer vacation day of my life
all of them
like when people hear it i don't think
they understand all of them
not like kind of you know like you meet
people they're like they helped out in
their family business every day
i was a terrible student my parents sat
me down at 14 and they're like you're
not going to harvard so you're going to
work every day
and so so work ethic was taught and then
i had such a gift of communicating that
my father really really impacted my life
because he has no tolerance for lying
and i had an incredible ability to
manipulate everyone on earth
and when you're young and you realize
you have gift of gab you have no idea
how to fully function with it
right and so
my dad really helped me because i was so
scared of him and for my father
embellishing or a slight exaggeration
was like a death blow
he keeps it so straight and that really
helped me a lot i i i think about that a
lot i was gifted with so many things but
i it really worked out for me on how
they parented me
but i but it all comes down to gratitude
when i tell you
the only thing on earth i care about is
the health of my family it is the only
thing i care about everything i do in
business is a game i don't give a [ __ ]
i money all of it health rule number
nine become more self-aware this is hard
the concept of teaching someone to be
more self-aware is something i've been
thinking about for a long time
you know i think the thing that drives
so many of us crazy in the world is
interacting with those that struggle
with self-awareness
i think one of the hardest things for
people to deal with is hypocrisy
we struggle with it and i struggle with
it um
the exercise in the book that i decided
to do was
creating
frameworks for the people that know you
the best
to create a safe space for them to be
able to tell you the truth
i think one of the
reasons
people struggle with self-awareness
is because they have enablers around
them that are allowing them to get away
with bad behavior
and so i'm spending a lot of time trying
to think about how one puts the people
that knows them the best in a safe place
to actually give them the critical
feedback that could be the jarror of a
journey towards self-awareness
it's a very tough challenge i don't know
if i have the answer
what i can tell you is
no question the business leaders that i
admire the human beings that i admire
are the ones who are off the charts in
self-awareness
i'm incredibly grateful for the luck of
the dna game that i think gave me a lot
of it i would argue that the only reason
i have any level of popularity
is because of self-awareness because of
the kind of communicator i am
and my personality i would be
completely not palpable if i didn't have
high levels of self-awareness because i
have some really funny attributes as a
communicator and so
it's a conversation we need more of
i do think that self-awareness has a
very interesting relationship with
accountability
i think that a lot of people actually
know
what their shortcomings are
but
they try to navigate the world
in a way where they are hoping that
people don't
notice and
it's something i'm thinking a lot about
and rule number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus clips is give
yourself permission to grieve i'm a big
believer that the world is doing a bad
job and not allowing people to grieve
when there are events that i'm assuming
are happening here my friend which i'm
so sorry for i don't think the world
does a good job on allowing to grieve
for example you would think me mr
rah-rah positive go go happy look on the
bright side would be the first person to
overwhelm you when something like that
happens to be like no it's okay they
want you to keep going they're looking
down and they wouldn't want you like
i feel like i on paper look exactly like
the person that would be at the
forefront of the no let's start the rest
of your life and they're looking down at
you and they love you and like which i
have those thoughts
comma
at 46 years old with the gray hair is my
belief
is that
we need to collectively as eight billion
people
create a better conversation around
grieving
um i really do uh i
for instance
have feel no pressure
on
getting back to work when i have a
moment like that happen in my life i
really don't
i will grieve
whether and i because i haven't been
through it it might take me an hour
because i could see that knowing my
chemicals and it could take me four
months and i can see that
because it could and by the way let's
all call
a spade a spade
the circumstances
also are a major variable like how did
you lose someone is it a tragic
ridiculously unfortunate accident that's
going to hit you different than a long
drawn out illness like there's a million
ways to think this true did you have
time to reconcile it because it was a
drawn out illness or was that even more
challenging because it was like a cloud
for two years there's just so many
circum what was your relationship
with that person of course like you know
people have parents and siblings and
spouses and children and loved ones but
i don't think anybody here is confused
we have different relationships with the
closest people in our lives that are
different than our
our you know our friends and family my
relationship with my mother couldn't be
more different than my dad's
relationship with his and so there's a
lot of variables that go into this
i often find that regret
is a huge driver of how someone reacts
this is why i over push people to over
communicate with the people they love i
think a lot of us get into our patterns
it was easier for me to talk to my
parents when i had an hour commute from
new york to new jersey and wine library
for five years than it is today i think
about it daily like do well do i feel
good about how often i'm talking to the
people i love knowing that everyone has
an expiration date my friend the answer
to the question is
give yourself time to grieve it's just
okay it's the most profound there's only
there's two profound moments in life
the moment someone is born and the
moment that someone dies there's a lot
of interesting stuff in between weddings
and other things but those are that's it
at its core that's it and i think that
they should be understood and we should
go deeper into them and i think we have
to be
um
more supportive of grieving
and letting people go through it
obviously you want to be supportive and
some people get into a spiral there's
people that are more positive by nature
there's people that are more negative so
you have to there's so many nuances to
this question but uh i
i'm a big fan of
one thing like a big big fan i say it a
lot i think that people judge themselves
too much
i just think all of you all of you are
beating yourself up too much about
things
the things you're not or
you know my sister's back to work and
doing great why am i sitting in this
dark room sad about my dad because
that's how you feel and that's okay and
i think we need to have that combo
look my friends you can't run away from
who you are
you can try to mold yourself into a
politically correct world and luckily
we're way beyond well not way beyond
this is unfair but i'm glad the world is
now focusing on other variables we'll
always have race and religion and sex
and those things but now we're leveling
up even into like what's a modern dad
and like you know what fit work life
balance and things of that nature
look i know the optics i know i'm living
a public persona i know i have to answer
these questions look how many work life
questions you got
i'd like to be politically correct i'd
like to be perfect i'd like to make it
easy on myself to not have to deal with
the stress of the optics on the outside
here is the punchline problem
you can't run away from who you are
you can't and so
i'm
[ __ ] ambitious like i want it i'm
careful to not give advice that i know
is uniquely something that i was gifted
with
like
i how do i tell you that oh here's how
it actually works and it almost started
happening it didn't happen like i
actually get goosebumps like actually
like real heavy goosebumps when i hear
something that i know feels right
what's the advice there hey johnny start
getting goosebumps like there's certain
things that i can't talk about because i
know they're not practical they're
intuitive to me right and so
yes for me it's the balance of i feel
like something's happening
but it always comes from seeing stuff
like it's it's it's going to the candy
store with my little guy and hearing
four eight-year-old girls talk about
slime and then later go to shake shack
and hear another two eight-year-old boys
talk about slime and i'm like slime and
then i search it this is like a year ago
and i searched it maybe actually it's 18
months ago and i search it on instagram
to see the hashtags i search on youtube
i search google i'm like this is real
there's something happening um spinners
right like fads are easy for me and i i
think what i've been good at in business
is trying to decide what's a fad
and what's an actual business so
something like social cam
i downloaded it and got very serious
about it in 2011.
i didn't know even the founders of
socialcam it wasn't that i knew if
socialcam was going to be big i didn't
invest in it i didn't go after it but i
knew video on the mobile device was
going to be big so when vine got hot
very quickly i was an early mover an
early advocate of vine and vine
influencers right which by the way vine
influencers are absolutely the precursor
to this snapchat instagram thing we're
dealing with right now that's where they
came from first instagram was photos
then when vine was dying a little bit
they all moved over to instagram
instagram was smart and made video one
minute videos and that's when you saw
the shift and that became the seed and
the foundation of instagram influencers
which is an enormous billion dollar
industry now everyone's like how are you
so early it's because i put in the work
2011 social cam learn how video and
mobile works 2013 comes along vine pops
i'm like that's right i lived through
youtube 2006 7 being a youtube celebrity
for my wine show so i knew what it
looked like i saw that the vine kids
were that um i flew to la and met
brittany furlon and king batch i put in
the work uh and so it's intuition but
it's also putting in the work when
you're scared or nervous or not
confident
a lot of people have dna that makes them
over compensate i call it a cactus
they're a cactus they're tough on the
outside but they're soft on the inside
the reason i keep telling everybody
kindness is a strength is i'm super nice
and super passive actually and like i'm
willing to let people take advantage of
me because i'm strong inside
so the question is you have to just know
if you're nervous if you're using
you know comp fake confidence to
actually hide something you're concerned
about humility
is an incredible strength that many men
and many people never want to show
i talk guys i put out content more about
me passing on uber and losing than i do
about the things i win on
everybody else puts out content of fake
wins
that's the difference
there's a big difference between the
people that bought you know beachfront
property in malibu than people that are
buying b trump property in in off region
no infrastructure islands in in in the
caribbean which is right in theory but
it could be an 80-year theory right and
so it's about timing like vr is coming
but consumer vr is very far away all my
friends are spending millions of dollars
tens of millions of dollars in consumer
venture uh virtual reality vr
yet there's nobody here nobody watching
this that knows a single person that
spends three hours a day on vr right
right like it's just it's just it's way
far away i'm not sure there's people
that know people that have spent three
hours in their life yet in vr right and
definitely not 10 people outside of
people in the business testing stuff so
i think timing really matters on that
because i get worried that people jump
way too far ahead and the reality is the
market's not there yet i think that i
could play basketball every day
every day of my life
from the time i was 15 and put in 15
hours a day and i think i'd be really
good i'd have a much better handle i'd
be i'd shoot better i would have been
more competitive with you at on the boat
that day um
but would i've been good enough to be in
the nba absolutely not maybe maybe d3
maybe college maybe yeah maybe and i do
think right now that everybody thinks
they can be an entrepreneur
and so my point was
it's it's much more talent than the
current conversation i i don't think you
can read
the school of greatness and my books and
all these other books and watch
skillshares and watch chase's harvest
and listen to ferris and and read
branson and and and and even go to
business school and and all and have
mentors and go to y combinator and then
all of a sudden just because of that you
become a great entrepreneur i think of
it like the music industry think about
all the kids that are born into you know
your clive davis's grandson or your
whitney houston's daughter or you have
nothing but access you're in the studio
all the time you learn the business but
if you don't have the chops if you don't
the vocals you're only going to go so
far it's much more talent than people
realize
i see it every day and the video i made
was like look you have to be okay that
by pouring in 18 hours a day and
learning everything might only allow you
to build a business that makes a hundred
thousand dollars a year right
there is an absolute misconception that
the american dream is entrepreneurship
and everybody can do it everybody the
difference between entrepreneurship and
football is everybody who's listening
right now or watching can start a
business
not everybody can go work out for the
new york yankees there's a system
there's no system in place for
entrepreneurship anyone can do it that
yeah at 16 or 22 stops you and says hey
man
you're going to lose a load of money and
be miserable and and literally you know
i'll be honest with you i'm i'm starting
this conversation
for quite a noble reason this is not me
to impose my will and say look how
special i am as a matter of fact i'd
rather think it's been the hard work
than the talent
you know i'd rather think it was
something i did versus mom and dad had
sex at the right moment
i'd much rather think that you can't be
all time if you didn't have results yeah
you can't just say you're one of the
greats i can't say i'm one of the
greatest batman players of all time if i
didn't do it yeah first you have to do
it yeah yeah um but the way he or she
does that is by putting themselves in
the best position to succeed
i met a kid last night business went
from zero to five million dollars in
sales in two minutes all instagram all
the [ __ ] i spewed i saved his life he
said i'm the best i'm 27 gary i'm high
energy i'm just like you and by the time
i'm 30 i'm gonna be a billionaire i
stopped them i said why are you even
doing that first of all you're probably
not because you're 27 you got 5 million
and i don't see anything that gets you
to a billion in your behavior right now
number two you pulled off a unbelievable
thing and you're downplaying your
success because you're telling smart
people like me you're going to hit a
billion and 30 and three years i'm gonna
see you and you're not gonna hit a
billion and you've put set yourself for
a loss and most of all and this is why
i'm telling the story
if you truly are convincing yourself
that you're going to hit a billion by
the time you're 30 and you're at 5
million from zero at 27 and you're not
going to pull it off
all your behavior for the next 36 months
is going to be predicated on short-term
behavior not long-term behavior and the
best way to make real money wealth not
being rich is to do things for the long
term because his life continues at 31. i
think that too many people when somebody
says something they don't like to hear
dismiss it as hate and a troll i read it
and question it
and then decide is there any merit to it
and the reason i've been able to evolve
is because i don't just default if
somebody disagrees with me or makes fun
of me that they're wrong i try to be
thoughtful about what are they doing
nine out of 10 times it's because
they're in a bad place and they're just
trying to drag me down but occasionally
there's a point there that i kind of
fester in it and start subconsciously
adjusting what i'm doing feedback is
important
51.49 i would run a 51 i'd run a slash
and i ran a 49. what's that mean
it would mean that i wanted to give
everybody that ever came across me 51 of
the value
and that's how i live my life i so know
what to do with the 49
that i want to give 51.
it's leverage
it's um it's how i think about it it
makes me feel good i love being liked
i louis look you and i run in similar
circles and around a lot of different
you know you know what i'm about to say
is so true and i'm very proud of this
and i am saying this because i want
everybody to hear it do you know how
nice it feels for me to know
that anybody that you talk to when my
name gets brought up that knows me even
a little bit thinks i'm great and only
the people that don't
don't
like whatever i have and hate or
they don't believe the hype or what's he
really about they just don't know me
yeah and anybody that spent any amount
of time like
listen there could be moments in time
but i know that the 137 times i've been
brought up in different cocktail parties
or things that that you you've rarely
heard from somebody who's interacted
with me
negative it's always been positive and i
love that yeah and that's 5149 man and
you don't think it's possible to to to
grow the entrepreneur i do
i think it's possible to grow anything i
think that i could be a better singer in
three years i think that i could be a
better basketball player do i think i
can become beyonce and lebron even if i
started at six years old no i do not
yeah that's right and so it but but you
have a better chance of being
a notch a master entrepreneur than a
master basketball player i don't know i
don't know is how i answered that i do
think that salesmanship and
organizational understanding and reverse
engineering and pattern recognition
is absolutely a talent and i think grant
it's funny you asked me that i think we
in the world have accepted music and
sports as a pure play talent and i think
entrepreneurship is something we think
everybody has and i do think everybody
can
and by the way
i think it's phenomenal
to go from working at a job and not
being on your own rules to making a
business that makes 89 000 a year but
you get to do it your way in a world
where people need to be more practical
meaning not everybody's going to be a
millionaire it's just the truth the
data's against you but it is phenomenal
to live a life where you get to make the
rules and you make enough money to live
your life in you view how aware of
are the average business leaders of the
correlation between employee engagement
and profitability
non-existent
because cfos are too literal an excel
sheet
and
90
if not 99
are not deploying emotional intelligence
above their financial intelligence
and they are
spreadsheet
basics
and
new kpis yes
how do we how do we clarify this
correlation because it is there research
shows is there you've seen it others
have seen it
research oftentimes and reporting
doesn't
penetrate a cliche
cfo
you know they no matter what your you
and i co i comment you know i come and
talk from personal experience somebody
else comes from an academic point of
view on this shows do you dear
cfo the you know you are wasting 4.9
million dollars a year of people sitting
there and and
crying and not working and if you had
better engagement
you know i i know that to be true in my
bones in my bones i know
that a proper culture
creates a scenario where people have
better output
in the time that they deploy i know that
is an intuitive human um
but if you're but now let's have some
empathy in the other direction
if you're the cfo of erickson
and you have to report numbers
and you have to report numbers every 90
days
it gets very hard for you
to make the investment
let's play this out okay
so
rick and susan hear us and they deploy
they're bought in they believe in you
and i what happens next well you have to
start putting in money to put into
programs
you have to put in money to put into
human beings that rev up the culture
they all of a sudden we ask the cfo
who's looking every 90 days
on a whim in their mind because it's not
mathematically quantitative no matter
what our reports show
they have to pour money in to this
for the hope that later it pays
dividends called investment i've heard
people don't invest
should i try to double or triple down on
my strengths within each business as far
as scheduling time doing my thing you
personally yes 100
okay like nothing i believe in more
than the fact that most people lose is
they waste time on trying to fix that's
never fixable
and what i mean by that is
what i mean by that is
i'm not going to be an nfl quarterback
and i'm not going to be not high energy
do you guys understand that if i was 13
less high energy
that i would be two times bigger there's
a lot of people that can't deal with my
energy
do you understand if i didn't curse that
i would have 12 million followers not
six
like people don't get it like but i'm
just a buyer of like being who you are i
could be so much bigger if i toned it
down a hair cleaned up a little language
today
not in 12 years
that's how i think about strengths and
weaknesses
one thing i love about athletes is
if if they get to the right place
mentally they're in a place where
they're always ready to get booed i
genuinely think the reason i'm super
successful
is because i got booed my whole life
i was an immigrant couldn't speak
english got booed
i was a terrible student
a couple miles away from here got booed
right
i was small not good enough at sports
got booed i got booted everything which
made me a great entrepreneur because i'm
ready to get booed i love being booed i
love elves the reason i love the jets
and knicks so much is they have one
i grew up a huge yankees and rangers fan
as soon as they won a title i was out
i'm about to climb i love losses i love
pain
i'm serious i love it i think that you
know
you know giving is intoxicating once you
get into it but you can't give if you're
not in a place of giving
and that doesn't mean money that means
happiness
and i you know i think i think at you me
others
i'm really really excited i think the
alpha male winner is starting to evolve
i don't think it means being a pushover
like some people get concerned that our
culture is getting too woke on that i
think it means rounded
in that like i i want i want people to
feel comfortable in this in their
selfishness
i love saying i'll do it right now i
want everybody to sign up for
winetext.com if you buy wine
now that's my dad's business but that
that is like my family business so
i want people to promote their thing i
wanted people to buy k-swiss i want them
to buy empathy wines i want them to go
to vaynermedia and vaynerx.com and work
with my companies i want that there's
nothing wrong with that
um and i don't want people to disguise
like you know like you know what happens
you get into this gratitude guilt frame
where when you're saying something you
hedge it with like but it's altruistic
i'm like you can have both you can be
altruistic and give and be awesome and
be selfish and have a boat and a house
and
millions of dollars like it's all good
and by the way you can also do whatever
you want but like but there is no
balance conversation right now it's
almost like you have to be foofy foofy
give away everything or completely rogue
i'm all about me and the reality is
everybody's in between
and i want to be great at both
right like like like
bleeding out of my eyeballs till three
in the morning this whole week every day
and being exhausted
but knowing that i'm one of the three
energies there's five energies alan tish
you know michael rubin the founder of it
and me and then fanatics's company and
vaynermedia's company they're working
right this second
um
that have helped in five days to raise
10 million that's gonna feed some kid in
mississippi some elderly woman in
westchester like like eat to eat
not to mention
all the happiness that comes when you're
the person that wins the
speaking role in leo and you're just a
normal person and for months you and
your friends are just happy every day
talking about it yeah 83 people in your
world
like there's so much good that can be
done
both selfless and selfish the reason so
many things are easy for me is i don't
give a [ __ ]
he's using my signature on a thing i
have no idea what he's talking about my
signature is my most important ip
and i don't give a [ __ ] because i like
him and fine nate did something when i
sell five bottles
15 cases 40k like but like do you know
how many people would freak the [ __ ] out
with that yeah like so like it just
matters the answer is very individual
you know
there's like most of the things i do
most people don't agree with
most of the things i do most people
don't agree with because i'm unique in
my lack of interest in short-term money
and i'm now starting to debate even
money in itself
i just like my process everybody's got
so much pressure to like have it figured
out when they come out of school like
it's time to be real in real life and
all that [ __ ]
stupid 22 to 30 should be experimenting
travel if you like and people like well
i don't have money i'm like you can
still travel you can get a [ __ ]
plane ticket you can take a bus like do
[ __ ]
so i think you're not going to find what
you like it's like food i'm always
fascinated by oysters
the amount of people that think they
hate oysters even though they've never
had one
i see so many people living life that
way you don't know your passion because
you haven't done billy i spend all my
time listening
the reason i want people to leave
comments is i read them
i read all the comments
i read the ones that say that i'm the
best i'm the read the ones that say that
i'm the worst i read the one and all i
do is i listen it's so funny i get made
fun of one askgaryvee because i'm always
interrupting people it's because i've
gotten so good at listening i know what
the people going to say before they say
it i just want to move on you know so
one of the ways to get the next clients
is to never let the last client fail
the only way not to let a client fail is
to over listen
and provide them what they want at all
costs which is why i always push against
people selling to the bottom because the
bottom doesn't know what to do with it
and then you're never going to win
you're just going to keep regurgitating
the bottom
and so that's how i did it i did it
first and then i listened very carefully
to the first 20 clients to make sure
there was no chance that there was going
to be any vulnerability and i built on
the word of mouth of our quality
deliverables for the client the
internet's here
it's a complete land grab
there's unlimited opportunity
nobody cares where you started nobody's
stopping you
there's nobody that's got to take your
resume there's no grades that matter
none of it what matters is are you
willing to hustle
and how bad do you want it
and are you willing to live a life where
you're not letting other people judge
you so then you're not pandering to it
you guys know grey goose
the guy who invented that as an
entrepreneur invented it at 78.
sydney frank
78 years old
you know
life is like sports like
one of the great moments of my life with
aj is the monday night miracle at the
meadowlands with the jets dolphins that
[ __ ] was 30 to seven in the fourth
quarter
and they won they came all the way back
my cousin left went home to queens went
to sleep i called him when they tied it
at 30
and said can you believe this he's
already sleeping he left that game and
was already sleeping in queens i was
like what are you talking about hung up
and then the dolphins scored i made it
37 30. and we blamed bobby for waking up
but like that's life like you could do
everything wrong
have every dream you've ever had
get [ __ ] up
blame it on other people the girl it up
that injury [ __ ] it up coach it up
blame everybody have everything go wrong
be 57 years old
and still have 40 years to make it right
it's crazy honestly like if there was
some crazy new drug that i could like
inject in you that gave you perspective
of time
you guys too
that's the drug i would give you
straight up
it makes you optimistic
people are sitting here dwelling already
dwelling already
i shouldn't come to rutgers i knew
it course there's people thinking that
like that's just real life
dwelling already haven't even
started
man that's what i want to change the
only thing that you can do wrong
is not being yourself
i see a lot of people scared to actually
be themselves because they're scared
who's watching and like i hate looking
at all your linkedin accounts you've got
like a suit and tie looking all
professional like you think something
bad is gonna happen if you're you're
normal i look like a mess
up here
i'm wearing a tierra whack
sweatshirt
like the results always win and i think
a lot of people hold back
their natural self
the market doesn't care in the end
somebody may judge you
but the market doesn't care i learn from
so much doing that's why my data is so
clean it's why i'm an innovator that's
why i'm fast it's why a lot of good
things happen for me because i realized
just the doing is actually more
efficient than the thinking about it
somebody said something really smart
funny to me once
and it was like the dig of this version
and it's a really funny conversation
he was talking about vaynermedia at the
time this was maybe five or six years
ago he said you know gary i gotta tell
you i love your company but i gotta
take a little bit of a knock on you he
was trying to set it up i'm like okay
what is it
he goes where i'm where i think you need
to be more thoughtful gary is
i have a feeling though that you might
run through that glass panel and sit
with us when you could have just opened
the door
and i said yeah but which one was cooler
evan thank you so much for having a
couple seconds and being able to tell
the believe nation a little bit about
empathy wines it means a lot to me that
you would take this valuable real estate
and and time on your channel to give me
some love means a lot it's just good
karma points and so you're just you're
awesome thank you believe nation uh if
you're into wine at all go to
empathywines.com
my whole career's work was poured into
producing a wine that rivaled 40 to 60
wine for 20 bucks a bottle uh i'm just
super excited about this
subscription-based wine business you can
order three six or 12 bottles in
subscription forum rose white red
if you if you search on instagram or or
twitter you will be blown away people
are literally like i don't even like
garyvee but the line is good super proud
of the effort thanks evan for the time
wishing you guys all happy and healthy
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the last one-on-one i did
with gary vaynerchuk check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there i'm talking about something
that the world thinks is a contradiction
i don't understand why anybody
should ever verbally dress down
an employee